I want to start from what I imagine you
all know and go from there and I want to
start with today's technology and this
is the inside of an FPGA a field
programmable gate array in it and it
kind of represents the state of the art
form from the point of view of an
approach to information processing based
on silicon and transistors and
conventional electronics that the thing
which is always plotted in Moore's law
over the last 40 years this is kind of
reaching its its it's end point and it's
reaching its end point for a very
obvious reason and that has to do with
the size of the wires that are inside if
you look at this this scale bar on this
diagram that's a hundred and twenty
nanometers if that means that these
wires are about 20 nanometer wires so at
some point not only can you not get
smaller but the physics of quantum
mechanics starts entering into the
problem in a bad way in this case the
physics of something like tunneling
through energetic lis forbidden barrier
is something that happens on these
length scales as you as the electrons
start to feel like that they're inside
of atoms instead of feeling like they're
inside of large wires but what's
interesting about this whole progression
from you know from 1947 and the
invention of the transistor all the way
through today is that there are a whole
bunch of features of physics I would say
features that are not controversial
physics that are part of even you know
undergraduate bachelor's education in
which there's essentially no
disagreement about that the correctness
of the ideas but which is not used and
it may be that it's not used simply
because everything else was working so
well and things were going along in a
great mad rush of technological
explosion until you get to the point
where things aren't you know getting any
better or any faster and then you start
to go back and you realize that there
were all of these things in in the
physics catalog that that somehow never
got used and maybe we're never needed
and they're they're a challenge to use
them I mean that's one reason probably
why they didn't
get used there they're not as easy I
should say as the technology that we
have today but they may be an extremely
promising resource and that's what the
talk today is about is about bringing in
other aspects of the physical laws that
govern the movement of electrons inside
of wires that that are not used um
this picture should look a little bit
familiar it's probably more familiar in
more polluted countries than Sweden and
Denmark but when a droplet of gasoline
or a droplet of oil lands on the surface
of water it's it's a rather familiar
sight to see the interference pattern of
the thin film of oil on the surface of
water I I would guess I'm gonna ask the
people in the first two rows because
it's all I can see familiar phenomenon
visually you've seen it before you might
have even taken a class in which you
solve the problem of which which parts
turn red in which parts turn green and
you would learned when you were in class
I didn't think you probably spent a lot
of time thinking about why it happens
but you learned at least how to
calculate things that would give you the
correct answer that metaphor is
something which will pervade this talk
which is it very often in physical
sciences we learn how to calculate
things when we get the right answer
without ever stopping to ask you know
what does it really mean so when we have
that when we want to calculate this we
say that you know in order to keep the
the the waves adding like this so that
they so that they double the the
amplitude and quotient you know in
square for the intensity instead of like
this where they cancel out you have to
be at a certain angle and that angle
tells you which ones are red and which
ones are blue and which ones are green
and you can set up all kinds of related
interference patterns and it's this kind
of interference pattern that we learn to
understand when we wrote down eventually
the the physics of light that light
should behave like a wave and that the
wave should show the properties of
interference in fact we it's kind of a
definition of what it means to be a wave
the wave is something in which there's
an amplitude and the amplitudes can
subtract to give you zero or they can
add to double etc water is another
example of a wave you can you can stick
your finger in
two places on the surface of water full
of water and if you stick your finger
here and here where I'm shining light
now it'll send radiating waves out
toward the edge of the boundary of the
pool of water and it's not a surprise to
anybody because if you've ever splashed
around in water you know that there will
be places like like right here oh sorry
there will be places like right here
where the waves from splash number one
in the way from splash number two added
up to make a an especially bright wave
sort of like when it turned green and
the waves were adding up and sink and
then there were other places like right
here where the minimum of one wave the
wave coming from one of the sources
added up with the maximum of the other
wave and it added up to given nothing
it's so far so good I really don't think
that this is a puzzlement and it should
be rather intuitive for the distance
away in general waves behave and you can
make this same kind of argument you can
figure out where they interfere
destructively shown here or whether it
interfere constructively and you can do
similar things with light you can have
two sources of light or two slits in a
pattern that lets light go through in
two slits and they'll do the same thing
they'll add up to places where the light
is bright and intensity in other places
where the light cancels out now all is
fine here's how you solve the problem it
doesn't matter um all is fine until you
recall what it was that Albert Einstein
got the Nobel Prize for and what was one
of his great accomplishments in 2005 was
the realization that light actually is
delivered in small packets called
photons and those photons are discrete
objects which will impinge upon for
instance your retina or anything that
absorbs light and that the energy from
that light will be delivered in a single
package and that without that phenomenon
you wouldn't be able to see nothing
would work and the whole physics of
light wouldn't wouldn't be as we
understand it so imagine the same kind
of experiment where you readily
acknowledge the existence of these
particles of light impinging upon the
screen as photons and
you imagine this is a cartoon but we'll
we'll talk about real experiments in a
bit here's a light gun that's shining
through two slits just as if it would
make these two radiating patterns only
now I've accentuated the fact that light
will land in the form of discrete events
on the screen so the the the photon that
lands on the screen right there will
make a spot and that that's I mean I'm
not saying anything brain bending by
saying that's where it is
that's where it was when it when it hit
the screen it had a location its
location is clear its location is the
position of the green spot but if you
continue to let the photons accumulate
you'll see a pattern on the screen which
resembles the interference pattern of
the light that propagated through the
two slits in pass through two slits so
evidently as the light was passing from
where the individual photons were
passing from this source through the two
slits they were delocalized like the
surface of a wave they didn't have a
location they must have been a wavefront
that passed through the two slits in in
a sense not having any particular
location like a wavefront doesn't have a
location but then when measured in
impinging upon the screen suddenly was
localized at some point now you could
say well there's a lot of photons and a
kind of a spray paint of photons but we
could let them go through very slowly
one at a time what I mean by one at a
time is that you can let the the
interval between photons be sufficiently
long that the the first one has already
gotten to the screen and made a blip
before the second one has even released
so you can really do the experiment one
at a time and you'll still see the same
pattern and you know you've probably
seen it before but you know in the
physical sciences and in most sciences
we have this process where we're after
enough times you begin to confuse
familiarity with understanding and I
think probably you've heard this you
know particle wave duality and all of
this say you know it's a hundred years
old
so but you have to stop for a minute and
say you know what is it what does it
really mean
take a crazy example like the wave front
of light that comes out from a distant
star and moves through space in some
radial pattern moving out from the star
then that light you know comes through
the millions of years of traveling as
light and then suddenly by a process
that is seemingly statistical it lands
in your eye and that photon is at your
eye
suddenly the information that says that
the photon is not in any of the other
places that it could have been in that
wavefront must instantaneously be
transmitted to the photons that were on
the far side of that star billions of
light-years away
now you think yourself well that just
sounds like [ __ ] I mean it's not
India obviously nothing nothing is
transferred to the other side
surely the photon that landed in my eye
was on its way all the time to my eye I
mean I might not have known where it was
until it got into my eye but surely
there was one there before it got to my
eye no that's not right you know that's
not right because the photon must have
been in all of those locations or else
the pattern wouldn't appear and we don't
have any better story to tell now than
the story that I just told you that is
if it sounds like [ __ ] I'm sorry but
there's no other story I mean which
doesn't mean it's not [ __ ] it just
means there is no there's no less less
[ __ ] sounding story than that one so
now I want to come back to electronics
into the the revolution that that this
idea and quantum mechanics set off and
bring it to the context of chips so
here's a surface of a semiconductor this
happens to be gallium arsenide doesn't
matter and it has a channel that's cut
into it where electrons can pass with
this way or that way and it's pretty
small and it's measured at low
temperatures so that so that the
measurement of the position of the
electron by all of the vibrations
latus doesn't take place and if you
apply an external magnetic field that
that takes the role of effectively
making one path longer than the other it
does the same thing as looking at
different positions on the on the screen
of bright dark bright dark patterns and
and what this tells you is that the
electron has proceeded from top to
bottom via both paths that is it was
delocalized during its journey it was in
both places at the same time if you want
to say it that way
and the evidence is this so-called
Aronoff Bohm effect of the interference
of an electron with itself now the thing
that makes electrons even more
interesting in a sense than photons is
electrons carry charge and charge can be
used for instance the charge on a
capacitor plate can turn a transistor on
or off so imagine now that we've said
that this electron is both you know
going both ways at the same time so this
one's going this way this one's going
this way and we use the charge that is
on this side when we say it's on this
side to turn a switch off and when the
charge is on this side we use that
charge to turn the switch on now we say
within this quantum mechanical picture
in which the charges in both places at
the same time that the that in that
sense the effect of that charge will
both flip and not flip the switch at the
same time so the switch will then be in
a state of left down right on and that
would be all you could say now if you
measured that it was left then the
switch would go to the down position but
if you don't measure it then you just
have to describe it as left down right
up now that's interesting because if
that switch is on it can let other
electricity flow and that electricity
could flow to the other side of the chip
and turn on another transistor and then
you'd have to say that if the charge was
on the left that the switch would be
down and the transistor would be
uncharged and the switch was up and the
charge was sorry I said it wrong on the
right to the switch was up and the
charge was in the electron was uncharged
so you have to keep all of those
possibilities coexisting
now where we're gonna go is that
nobody's ever built one of these things
before this is all perfectly good even
you know boringly old-fashioned
statements about quantum mechanics but
it's never been done I want to just say
some notation because I'll use it in a
little bit um you can think about like
computer scientists and call these
things zeros and ones and then you can
say that the the state can be in a 0 and
a 1 at the same time you can use in
physics we characterize the state of a
two-level system a system that can be in
one of two states as looking like a spin
vector so we can call it up and down
same thing and then the rule of quantum
mechanics that we've discussed so far is
this idea that things don't have a
particular state until they're measured
there in both states as possible so we
can say that this quantity which we'll
call sy the wave function can be in some
kind of superposition of being down and
up at the same time and that's allowed
within the laws of physics and something
that is certainly not used in any chips
that we build the amount of up and the
amount of down doesn't need to be 50/50
and so we can characterize all the
possible super positions in the
following way let's call down something
like a down arrow and oh sorry 0 a down
arrow and 1 an up arrow and then all the
possible super positions given the
constraint that they should add up to
some total probability can be written as
any position of that vector on the
surface of a sphere so that for instance
if it's a 50-50 mix of 0 and 1 we'll
call it the east direction if it's a
negative version that's right the
amplitudes can be negative in fact they
can even be complex so these a and B
variables can be complex numbers and so
any arrow on the surface of a sphere
represents the generalization to quantum
mechanics of what used to be called a
binary variable or a bit so this thing
will get the name a qubit to represent
the two-level system of a binary
variable now in its quantum mechanical
generalization including the possibility
of complex superpositions of those two
so you see it's a pretty technical talk
now in in computer science this is the
subject that you all know and I don't
know so you know what I want to learn
about computer science I just watched a
YouTube called how to add numbers in one
lesson and this is about the extent of
my knowledge of classical computing
however what I know is that there are
combinations of of gates like an or gate
and a not gate NAND gate that can
produce any possible set of gates and so
I wanted to talk about this Universal
set of gates for a classical computer
out of which you can build in principle
any possible computer and to say that
there is an analog of that in quantum
computer science which says that if you
have a couple of possible gates namely
something called a unitary that unitary
that u stands for unitary and what it
says is it's sort of the analog of a not
instead of saying it to goes from a zero
to a one or one to zero
it takes you from some state to some
other state of that variable and it's
more general than a not because it can
go to any possible angle but what it
does is it rotates you from one to
another one other gate which is sort of
you know like a like an X or it's the
it's the analog of an X or it says if
this one is a
if this one is up then leave the the one
it touches alone if this one is down
then flip it and so this thing which
which couples to and and and will be the
the embodiment of something that we'll
learn in a minute it's called
entanglement but here we just say that
this is a kind of a gate that if this
one is up it leaves it alone and if this
one is down it and if it's down it flips
it are all that you need unit Ares and
these X ORS are all you need in order to
build a universal machine in which any
possible computational function in the
full quantum mechanical space can be
realized okay so it's a kind of a
theorem for quantum computing but what
we've really done in thinking about this
is written that the state of a computer
let's say that these numbers represent
the state of every transistor in a so
this is should be you know this should
be a billion zeros long for representing
the state of every transistor and that
this will go all the way down to every
transistors in the on position to every
transistor is in the off position and
what we've said is that the wave
function of that chip must look like a
superposition of all of these possible
states with some mixture of ratios of
all of them which can be complex numbers
and so if I think of this thing as n
transistors that means that there's two
to the N of these objects and that means
that the description of the state of the
computer is a point in a 2 to the n
dimensional space now if you think for a
minute that if I had for instance 300
transistors that the dimension of the
space in which the point is located is
more than all the you know every proton
in the universe okay so very quickly the
space in which this system lives as a
point in a vector space that's 2 to the
n dimensions becomes astronomically big
and then you say how could I possibly
have a computer in which there's a point
that's moving in a space that has more
dimensions than there are particles in
the universe
and I don't have an answer for that
except to say you know maybe those are
in other universes somewhere and I want
you to know I know that sounds like
[ __ ] but nothing that I'm saying is
disagreed upon within the community okay
there's a there's a I mean by the
community I mean physicists and you know
this is standard stuff it's just you
know we use it we write it down and we
learn to calculate where the bright spot
is and we forget what it all means and I
haven't even touched on the weird parts
yet because in fact imagine we did the
following experiment
take a helium balloon and take one atom
of helium as you remember a helium atom
has two electrons circling circling and
nucleus and the two electrons are in the
lowest shell that's why it's a noble gas
and the two electrons if you did take
chemistry class or physics class you'll
remember that they fill the first shell
one goes in spin up and one goes in spin
down and then the first shell is filled
and then when you have to make the next
element you have to you have to go out
to the next shell this shell is full so
take the two electrons that make up this
condition and in fact we don't write
usually ones up and ones down because
you don't know which one is want which
and which one is the other so you write
a superposition of this ones down this
ones up and this ones up and that ones
down and you put a minus sign in between
so that they obey the laws of electrons
which is when you switch their place the
overall wavefunction has to take on a
minus sign that's a bit of a detail
although it's gonna come back later so
in any case there's a minus sign we
choose a minus sign but you don't care
just let's call it this with my thumbs
ones up in ones down but you'll remember
that that means ones up and ones down or
the other way and take them and separate
them a long distance a very long
distance without disturbing their
orientation and send one with some
distance away and the other one another
distance away
and then measure one of them because
they're oppositely oriented if you
measure one of them the other one will
be naturally oppositely oriented but
what's interesting about that statement
is I didn't suggest when you measured
this one over here
what orientation you would put your
detector I mean maybe you would turn it
sideways or maybe you would oriented
some orientation and no matter how you
oriented it this one would be the
opposite so somehow the act of measuring
one would connect through space
instantaneously somehow in effect not
just its own outcome but the outcome of
its partner this level of unbelievable
Nevada Dine Stein in 1935 late in his
career this is a picture of Einstein in
1935 so he was a guy by then and and yet
the paper this I'm Stein Podolsky and
Rosen paper with this grammatically
challenged title can quantum mechanical
description of physical reality be
considered complete is these days his
most cited work if you go to Google
Scholar you type a Einstein to see how
many how many how many hits all the
papers have this is number one because
of the controversy that this paper
created by talking about this separation
because you remember Einstein from
relativity said nothing travels faster
than the speed of light and let you
measure the basis of a spin in this
direction and it gets set in the other
one and the conclusion of this paper was
one is thus led to conclude that this
description of reality given by the
wavefunction is not complete and the
paper was careful to not say wrong
because you can calculate things with
and you get the right answer it's just
that it simply must be some kind of
provisional understanding that must not
be the deep penetrating truth of what's
really going on because it you know it's
because it sounds so crazy
and um it's very interesting what
happened during this period 1935 the
same year that was from March the same
year in July so it didn't take bore very
long to write a response paper with this
exact same grammatically challenged
title can quantum mechanical description
of physical reality be considered
complete and to summarize Bohr's
response he said in fact this new view
of natural philosophies he bore
understood this wasn't a statement about
physics this was a statement about
everything this was a statement about
the way we think the universe is but
it's not that when you do something
somewhere it can't have an instantaneous
effect somewhere else and and yet what
what Bohr it seems correctly these days
said was that this requires a radical
revision of our attitude as regards
physical reality and that was 1935 and
between then and now I mean as you can
imagine experiment is the arbiter of
whether this is true or not who wins the
Bohr Einstein debate is not who's a
better arguer it's how did the
experiments come out and so immediately
this is it took a while but this was you
know circa 1972 thirty years after the
Borenstein episode in 1935 this was
reduced to an experimentally testable
practice by a guy named John Bell who
said if you set up the following
experiment you can find out whether or
not those states were predetermined
before they were measured or whether or
not the act of measuring this one
determine the outcome of that one and
all of those experiments right up to the
present day so here's from from a year
ago 2015 where now these two are
separated by more than a kilometer in
the detector sorry Einstein quantum
study suggests spooky acts spooky action
at a distance is real so every
experiment that's been done between then
and now has verified this idea that not
only does the does a system not have a
state until it's measured but if it's a
multi particle system with correlations
across the system measuring one will
instantaneously determine the other
and it may be that the difficulty of the
intuition of understanding this which
frankly doesn't matter I mean if it if
we don't have an intuition for something
that doesn't mean it's not true that
just means that that our evolution
didn't require an intuition for it in
order to survive
so that's right we don't have any
intuition for this it seems like it's
wrong to us but why should we have an
intuition for how things work inside of
atoms or how they work in milli Kelvin
temperatures or how they work in photons
that have been prepared in some way that
wasn't that didn't exist until we
evolved to do it another way of saying
what I just said I quote famous American
theoretical physicist Richard Feinman
quantum mechanics describes nature as
absurd from the point of view of common
sense and yet it fully agrees with
experiments so I hope you can accept
nature as she is absurd but now when we
think about information technology we
can imagine that we set a transistor
here that sets electricity to go over
here or doesn't at the same time and
sorry and it doesn't at the same time
and that flips a switch which turns this
on and doesn't turn it on at the same
time and and sets the whole chip in some
state of this exponential number of
possible states because every time you
get to an X into an intersection you
have to remember that each one could or
could not go into the following state
and then and then you you know measure
this one and it suddenly sets that one
which determines what this one is across
the chip it's all consistent with the
laws of quantum mechanics and it's never
been built and that to me is enough of a
challenge to dedicate myself to trying
to do it because it just seems really
cool but there was an added kicker that
brought the attention of the world and
the added kicker is is this in 1903 in
1996 Peter shor then Bell Laboratories
now at MIT wrote a paper that said the
following in the abstract
a digital computer is generally believed
to be an efficient universal computing
device that's this Universal classical
computer that I talked about this may
not be true in quantum mechanics is
taken into consideration that is there
may be problems that cannot be
efficiently simulated on a computer what
this paper considers is a problem which
is hard factoring integers now factoring
integers doesn't seem that hard but it
is a hard mathematics problem and what
Peter shor showed in this paper was that
if you had a machine that could do that
thing that I talked about in the
previous slide um you could solve that
problem very fast so here's the problem
I think you know the problem the problem
is one it's a big part of RSA algorithms
were for secure communication two
numbers that multiply together to give
you two prime numbers that multiply
together to give you a known number so I
give you the known number you have to
find the two prime numbers I can only
see the first two rows does anybody know
what those two numbers might be yeah
what are they yeah yeah he says but then
he does but then he doesn't know okay
yeah five and three okay okay mr. yeah
yeah yeah two prime numbers that
multiply together to give you four
thousand six hundred and thirty three
twenty three and twenty one is not
correct
41 and a hundred and thirteen and each
of you can ask yourselves how do you how
do what I have done that how would I
figure that out I think you're kind of
you know it's not like you missed that
day in school where they taught you how
to find those those numbers there isn't
a good efficient algorithm for solving
that problem and in fact as the problem
gets bigger it gets harder much faster
so the RSA algorithm asks the question
if I give you this number
can you find these two prime numbers
that multiply together to give you that
number and that is a problem which is in
solvable of course if I give you one of
the numbers then you know it's
instantaneous that you can divide one by
the other
find the other one but but to find the
two is insolvent what what I mean by
that is this oh sorry I'm gonna skip I
put this one in here twice sorry about
that
here's what I mean by that as the number
of bits in gets to be gets to be large
then a computer or a hundred computers
more or less however fast they are if
you take the clock speeds from 2003 when
the paper was written or the clock
speeds extrapolated to 2018 it doesn't
matter once you have a thousand bit
number
it takes the age of the universe to
solve the problem but depending on the
clock speed going from gigahertz
megahertz even kilohertz if you have one
of these quantum computers that can keep
all the parallel States alive at the
same time the problem becomes much
simpler now I and many others were
already interested in this problem
because it was a cool problem but this
is when the world lit up when the idea
that internet security could be
compromised if somebody had a quantum
computer um got things going but I want
to emphasize and I think that this is a
really a maybe the key point for the
talk that's not the end of the story and
and how could it be I mean this is such
you know the idea of computing in in a
billion dimensional space cannot be just
good for factoring numbers and solving
internet problems but what's an active
area of study now is exactly what
problems that we need computational
advances in can be addressed by using
this kind of superposition and to a
large extent it's not known it's not
known what class of problems can be
accelerated by using a quantum computer
current work so here's from you know May
of this year addresses some some
interesting problems here's one about
finding a the the the ground state of a
chemical that is used in the production
of fertilizer which you know is also big
business
so there's a there's a there's an iron
atom in the middle of some large complex
and it's it's it's used to in in the
production of the catalysis of
fertilizer and so this was how you know
how can you find the ground state of
that molecule it's relatively simple
molecule and how many of these qubits
would you need to do it so this is one
example of a problem where you can solve
it but depending on the details of what
kind of errors the qubit haves whether
whether the rotation angles for this
unitary rotation makes an error of one
part in a thousand or one part a million
or one part in a billion you may need
something like a billion cubits or ten
million cubits or a million cubits now
that sounds like a lot but actually you
know there's a billion there's a billion
cubits right here so I mean there's a
billion bits right here anyway so we
just have to make the version of it
which respects the quantum mechanics so
I don't think that the that the problem
of step-and-repeat
to make a billion things is the hard
part or maybe it was the hard part but
we already solved that problem the
problem is to get the quantum coherence
into the system in the first place
without it getting hard as we scale it
up so we're beginning now these are
really brand new kinds of results to
begin to understand what kind of machine
would we need to build and it's very
interesting that the hardware builders
like myself are in the exact same
situation as the the theorists who
trying to figure out what to build in
parallel I think it's a different it's
it's a different kind of field than most
where we don't know exactly what it is
that we're trying to do we're trying to
figure out to build a few qubits while
at the same time people trying to figure
out what what it is that we'll do with
them but it's not surprising that
industry has entered into the problem so
you know IBM Google Microsoft all the
big companies are now beginning to
invest and governments also so there was
just announced this year a billion euro
program in the out of the European
Commission to study this and other
quantum technologies that take advantage
of superposition entanglement and these
other attributes so
keep in mind the time line this was you
know the 1930s when people were
understanding that this physics was
correct the 1990s when people were
realizing that certain problems could be
solved with this but it's not until now
that people have begun to make hardware
and begun to see the first few qubits do
what they're supposed to do and now you
see this great pouring of interest into
the problem I'm going to ask somebody
who has a watch on because my my
battery's dead what time is it
okay so a lot of interest is pouring
into this problem but I I mean what I'm
gonna report to you is that the progress
is is difficult and you know pretty
pretty incremental at this point I'll
talk about two examples of technologies
that are going on in my own lab not
because they're better than what's going
on in other labs but because I know
about them and I'll mention some things
that are going on in other people's labs
but I but I just I don't know about them
as much so one example was how do you
make your first qubit oh I discovered
something if I stand back here I can see
okay it's open for questions now anybody
who wants to ask questions I can see you
now as long as I stay back here it's
okay if I stay back here am I out of the
light now you can't see me right if I
come back up here you disappear and I
appear okay
so here's an example first of all it's
an example that shows you don't need to
spend very much time on graphics in
order to have an influential paper but
what this paper said in a time when it
wasn't technologically possible was if
you could make a box and you could put
one electron in the box like you could
make a transistor like a capacitor plate
that could hold one electron then if you
could connect those two capacitor plates
so that they would make one big
capacitor plate for some controlled
period of time the during the time that
there were two electrons on a capacitor
plate they would try to do the thing
that helium did which is that they would
try to go into some opposite spin
orientation and then you could separate
them and you could use that as a kind of
a control mechanism for how
do this thing where if this one stays
this one flips and if this one doesn't
stay then this one's down then it flips
the other guy you could do that by just
using the laws that made the helium atom
in the first place all you'd need to do
would be to make a box that could hold
one electron and you could read it out
by trying to see the orientation of that
electron by putting it in contact with a
ferromagnet etc they honestly these
theorists went a little farther than
then was their own comfort zone about
how you do all the rest of it but they
worked out the math of how you do this
interaction to show that it was the same
as that two qubit gate that you needed
in order to do universal computing so
the the idea was that the desired
operations are affected by the gating of
the tunnel barrier between two
neighboring dots and it would produce
Universal we propose an implementation
of a universal set of 1 & 2 cubicle
quantum gates so you know no idea that
it was the best thing to do but it
seemed doable and it was one of the ones
that I took on about 10 years ago to
give this a try the first thing that had
to be invented was a box that would hold
one electron the way we did it was by
taking gallium arsenide and putting
metal on the surface of it this is a
so-called two dimensional electron gas
heterostructure of two different kinds
of gallium arsenide with with an
electron system that lives at the
surface and we put metal on and not
surprisingly if we put negative voltages
on the metal the electrons don't like to
go near the negative voltages so they
stay away this is about one micron from
side to side so it's not particularly
small compared to modern technology it's
just that this is a material that is
basically free from disorder so we can
make a box of electrons here and a box
of electrons there and we could measure
where the electrons were and we could
then go to begin to do the helium
experiment that I talked about earlier
which is to say that we could put the
two electrons here whose ground state
would be this up down - down up singlet
configuration we could then change the
voltages on those gates separate the two
electrons and see how long it took to
have those two electrons be independent
subsequently measure them but all we
wanted to do for this experiment was to
hold them apart for a while and to ask
the question how long can you hold those
two electrons apart before they lose
their singlet correlation before this
idea of separating them and then
measuring them later falls apart and the
way we did that was by eventually trying
to put them back in the
name box so this is a little bit more
complicated but we would prepare
separate in measure P s M by taking the
two electrons stayed here the ground
state was the singlet configuration we
would separate them to what was a mix of
the singlet and the triplet the parallel
oriented spins then separate them and
ask did they go back into the state or
not go back into the state and we found
something very interesting when we did
that when we asked the question do you
go back into the state that you came
from or not we got an extremely
surprising result which I think will
surprise you also which is when we
separated the two electrons for
something like 10 nanoseconds or 20
nanoseconds separate them leaving there
and then try to put them back in the
same box they all went back in the same
box again here they all went back as a
singlet again but if we waited something
like 50 or 60 nanoseconds none of them
went back in the box they had turned
into a triplet but then if we waited 120
or so they all went back in and then not
and then yes and then no and then yes
and then no and even if you look
carefully you see even the period is
inconstant it's kind of faster down here
than it is over here so there was
something that was taking these two
electrons and screwing with them but in
a kind of a periodic way so that they
were processing one relative to the
other and it took us a long time to
figure out what the what the rate of
procession wasn't even constant time so
something was causing this procession it
would have to be something like a
magnetic field that would make up a spin
process where how could there be a
magnetic field difference between the
two sides on a few hundred nanometers
separation what kind of what kind of
magnetic field would have a strong
enough gradient over 100 nanometers that
it could make this happen
well eventually we figured out what it
was and it was as surprising to us as it
probably will be to you which is that
there's an effective magnetic field
produce by the gallium and the arsenic
nuclei that live inside the crystal that
is we make these things out of gallium
arsenide but gallium and arsenic have
nuclear spins in the nuclei of those of
those atoms was causing the electrons to
process around the nuclear spins I mean
who would have thought that we had to
worry about the nuclei
of the atom of the semiconductor crystal
that we were working with but that was
performing the measurement so then life
went on things got more tricky and other
people this is from it from a different
group this happens to be from the group
and in Delft started working with other
materials they specifically pick
materials that didn't have nuclear spin
now interestingly a material that
everybody here is familiar with silicon
is a material that doesn't have any
nuclear spin well actually that's not
quite true silicon-28
the predominant species of silicon and
germanium is a same story is mostly
silicon 28 is is nuclear spin 0 great so
at least that problem won't exist but
there's this residual 4% that silicon 29
in naturally-occurring silicon and those
spins were enough to cause the problem
so when people moved to a silicon
silicon germanium quantum dot to do
these experiments later same problem
from the residual 4% so then came a
whole community of people who were
interested in trying to produce 99.9999%
pure silicon 28 now you'll notice the
nationality of a lot of the of the
authors of this paper and and these were
the these were the communities that used
to be spinning plutonium in their in
their centrifuges in the soviet union
they're now in the business of purifying
silicon to make quantum computers and
other applications as well but so the
motivation was to get rid of this decoe
hearing mechanism once we had discovered
it so you know you could say is this
technology or is this physics and you
know I don't know but in any case each
time you discover something that's
measuring the spin that you want to be
left
unmeasured you then have to start a
whole technological approach to get rid
of it so where are we now well you know
we have now rows of quantum dots here's
15 of them in a row and we can move them
around and gate them and you know it's
far from being a quantum processor but
it's a technology in which we can
measure a long coherence time for these
spins and we can measure where they are
by using these sensors at the top
and it becomes now a control problem to
try to measure them there are other
technologies with this is based on a
superconductor this is from John
Martinez's group this was when John
Martinez was a University of California
Santa Barbara John Martinez now works
for Google and is doing the same thing
there but here you know it's pretty
similar to the status of what I talked
about before this is five quantum dots
that are all in a row and here it's
announcing something called the
threshold for fault tolerance and what
that means is if the individual errors
of the qubits are sufficiently small
this rotation angle for instance is
sufficiently small then you can correct
the error without doing any measurement
that is remember you're not allowed to
measure because then you determine the
state and it locks it in but you can
still do error correction without doing
any measurements but you need it to be
pretty good already and so this is a
paper that claims yes it's only five
cubits but now there have sufficient
quality that we've reached the threshold
where we can correct the errors that
occur using a so-called quantum error
correction algorithm it's time to wrap
it up but there's a separate subject
that I want to talk about and so I'm
going to take five minutes or something
like that to just to just change
subjects which is the introduction of a
new idea into physics and into quantum
computing namely topology so I think
maybe maybe if you had a math class
where you've just you know in awake for
your lives you've you've you've heard
about this idea that say in this case
some loop I don't want to call it a
circle because it doesn't matter that
it's a circle can be deformed you know
by going like that into this figure
eight design but cannot be deformed
into something that has a non-trivial
topology so we can distinguish these two
from this one by the over-under routes
of the string and that branch of
mathematics that distinguishes this
shape from that shape is called topology
and what is it what's its relationship
to quantum information or what's its
relationship the information processing
in general well I think you can imagine
that
tying a knot in something is a very good
way to store information in fact the you
know this was done in Mesoamerica for
centuries and these things can still be
dug up and the knots are also there and
there the encoding of how they would how
they would hold information in knots
lasts for a long time the U in order to
get the information out you have to read
the knot and take it out and it's you
know it's hard to remove that
information much harder than destroying
a piece of paper for instance so you
could ask is there an analog of this can
we take the wave function of some
quantum mechanical system and tie it in
a knot in some way that that knot is
hard to remove can we encode topology in
the wave function and give it the kind
of stability that a knot has and the
answer is maybe but first we have to
invent a particle that will remember
that it's been tied in a knot and there
aren't any so far maybe the particles
that we live with are called fermions
and bosons and that's this thing that I
were that I told you about electrons
already that if you switch two of them
around you need a minus sign those are
fermions electrons and most of the
particles that we're used to these days
if you switch if you take two of them
and you switch them there you get a
minus of the wave function which means
if you switch them twice which is the
same as wrapping one around the other
one you come back to the same wave
function no memory no memory that one
particle went around another bosons are
the other kind of particles that we live
with right now and in either case if you
surround one by the other nothing
happens but in lower dimension there can
be particles that remember when one
particle has encircled another and in so
doing changes the wave function it's as
if they have like a string hanging down
in the third dimension below them and
when you move them around each other it
tangles the strings around each other
and in a way what we would like to try
to invent would be a system of all of
these particles and they're all moving
around each other and what's coming down
below is like weaving and that the cloth
that's produced from the memory of the
particles going around each other is the
memory of what what computation has been
done if we could only make particles
that do this and so
the last bit of my talk was to talk
about this I'm a little shy on time so
I'm probably not going to spend that
much time but it is interesting that if
you did see who won the Nobel Prize in
Physics this year and what it was for
these guys Duncan Haldane David Salas
and Michael costal it's got the Nobel
Prize for studying topological states of
matter and if that didn't make any sense
to you there's a nice description and
now you see why they're talking about
flatland because it has to be in this
reduced dimensional space so that the
string can hang down into three to the
imaginary string can hang down into
three dimensions and it's interesting if
you read the citation on them on the
Nobel website it says topological
insulators topological superconductors
topological metals are now being talked
about these are examples of areas which
over the last decade have defined the
frontline of research in condensed
matter physics not least because of the
hope the topological materials will be
useful for new generation of electronics
and superconductors or in future quantum
computers so what's that all about
how do we compete with them well that's
what I wanted to end with I think that
in this for the sake of of time because
I'm probably pretty much out of time
holiday yeah so then I'm gonna skip
forward and not tell you a long
interesting beautiful fantastic history
of these devices unfortunately but
instead to say that that they look like
this
these are wires nano wires made out of a
single crystal of material with aluminum
that has been grown on the surface and
the aluminum at low temperature
superconductors and the combination of
super conductivity the material
properties of the semiconductor which
includes something called spin orbit
coupling an applied magnetic field can
produce a particle that theoretically
has these so-called I'll give you the
term for it non abelian particle
statistics meaning they remember when
you move them around each other and so
we're now in this game where we're
actually much more primitive than than
the rest of the qubits because we're
trying to do it in this crazy
topological way this is also going on in
the lab and we hope that there are these
so-called Meyer onna zero modes these
particles that have these statistics
located along this wire and I just
wanted to give you a little tour of what
this thing looks like in the lab that's
what the device looks like we use these
things to measure where the my Arantes
are and they live at the boundaries of
the superconductor that's the device
right there it's connected via all of
these wires that when you zoom out let
me go back one when you zoom out it
looks it's connected here that goes out
to the edge of the chip here's what that
chip looks like on the refrigerator on a
circuit board that lives inside of a
copper box the copper box lives at the
bottom of a machine that goes to 10 mili
degrees above absolute zero so we take
the entire device down eventually it
gets all buttoned up here and there's a
sign on the outside that says caution
strong magnetic fields but inside of
there that little chip is sitting at ten
million degrees one hundredth of a
degree above absolute zero
with these new non-abelian particles
that remember when they've been wrapped
around each other as possibly the basis
of a future technology
now life is gonna have to get more
complicated and the theoretical results
that say how to move these things all
around each other each one of those X's
is one of these topological properties
and it's all happening right now it's
all happening now that the theory is
coming out and saying if you can make
these non abelian particles if particles
can remember that they've gone around
each other
here's how you can make the fabric of a
computer that will remember and will be
as immune to decoherence as a knot tied
in a wave function now that's pretty
exciting if it works to me it feels like
pure physics but to the technologists
that support it and I have to say
Microsoft supports a huge effort in our
lab to do this is this idea that maybe
this is going to be the answer to cloud
computing this or the spins in the
semiconductor or the the superconducting
qubits that Google is making all of
these are interesting technologies and I
want to end with this slide which is the
response if you haven't been browsing
the NSA website lately I'll show you
this page from from the National
Security Agency which is they are
worried about the existence of these
machines I'm worried about the failure
to make one of the machines but they're
worried about the non failure and so you
can see that what they say is below we
announced this is an announcement on the
NSA website below we announced
preliminary plans for transitioning to
quantum resistant encryption algorithms
algorithms that are provably immune to
quantum encrypt to to having a quantum
computer what's the mathematics of
proving that it's not possible it's also
an opened beautiful math problem without
I'm going to end I've given you a little
taste of an advanced technology that
stick around let's see how fast it
develops thanks
[Applause]